okay I don't want to spend too much time
on this since it's not really the type
of story that we can really add too much
to but it's been in the news for days
and it all came to a head very early
this morning so I do want to mention
that the serial Texas bomber who's been
terrorizing mostly Austin Texas as well
as some nearby locations with a variety
of package and parcel bombs is now dead
after blowing himself up police started
closing in on the 24 year old white male
in a hotel parking lot in Round Rock
Texas very late last night less than 20
miles from Austin found inside his car
this is the individual believed
responsible for five explosions you'll
see as we look at them on a map for our
television audience four in Austin plus
one at a Federal Express facility FedEx
facility in Schertz Texas closer to San
Francisco as well as a bomb stopped from
exploding at another FedEx facility and
the way this went down is that police
waited for a SWAT team to arrive when
they tracked this individual to his
vehicle the suspected bomber started
driving away eventually stopped on the
side of the i-35 frontage road in
outside Austin Texas SWAT approached and
the bomber detonated a bomb in the
vehicle and it injured one of the SWAT
officers ultimately he also the the
bomber was shot by a SWAT officer and we
actually don't know whether the medical
cause of death was the bomb that he set
off himself or being shot by the SWAT
officer but the total death and injury
toll from this harebrained reign of
terror is two dead and five injured of
course not including the bomber himself
and there are already some indications
from a suspected blog of the Bombers
that he is a self-described conservative
who was against gay marriage who knows
we'll see ultimately if that ends up
being his blog or someone with the same
name the real questions now are why did
he do it
from a public safety perspective did he
leave behind more bombs either in the
mail or in the
Beks delivery system or maybe in public
utilize the trip wire on one device and
it's horrible to have to extend this but
we have to recognize that parcels can
take several days to work their way
through the mail and package delivery
system so it's possible that something
was mailed and is still there people in
the area still being told to be very
vigilant about weird packages packages
that they're not expecting and then the
other question is did he act alone and
that's actually a big question because
if he did act alone then presumably
within a couple of days any package is
sent by this individual would either
have exploded or hopefully been defused
identified and diffused if he's not
acting alone I think we can all kind of
imagine that it's not a good situation
and I actually you know a lot of people
online think they're great glad that
this guy is dead I'm glad he's no longer
able to do the things he was doing
but I would actually much prefer being
able to have law enforcement interview
the guy and figure out what are the
motives because we often never learned
in these depraved cases what actually
were the motives of the perpetrator I
think that that would be incredibly
useful to us and one one interesting
little thing I was thinking of all along
media reports mostly would talk about he
when referring to the bomber sort of
assumed that we're talking about a male
here and it's accurate right like it's
never a woman that is involved in this
type of thing and I actually wonder like
do law enforcement agencies even have to
discuss that like do they sit around and
they go okay anybody think we might be
looking for a woman no no it's it's a
male we're looking for or is it just so
obvious that this is the work of a man
that it doesn't even have to be
discussed that law enforcement just
knows yeah same thing with shootings too
right after a shooting yeah you don't
typically know the race or the religion
of the perpetrator yeah but we always
know that it's the man you don't even
need like a gender-neutral term for it
you don't need to say gun person it's
always done man or they you sometimes
hear they as opposed to he and I know
some people will write to me and they'll
say David that's wrong here is an
example of a woman who participated in a
bombing here's an example of a woman who
participated in a shooting and of course
Mystikal II it exists but it is almost
never the case and I wonder whether that
is made explicit by law enforcement who
works on a case like this or if it's
just they figure statistically speaking
it's probably a white male between 20
and 45 years old which is typically what
it is I had a conversation yesterday
with my girlfriend and before we knew
anything about the identity and she said
what do you what what do you think the
profile is eventually going to be and I
said probably a white male age 20 to 45
that's what yeah that's what it usually
is the motive we don't always know for
her he could have been a right-winger
could have been a left winger and now it
seems like he was a right winger yeah
and in fact they were trying to push the
narrative that bombs are sort of more
like a left-wing eco-terrorist or an
Tifa type of thing and listen so far it
appears he was a right winger but
clearly somebody who this is not an
excuse but who also was severely
mentally disturbed which anybody would
have to be in order to do something like
this
today's program is made possible in part
by futur futur is a social forecasting
game where you compete with other
players to predict the future and it's
built on the principles of what's called
a prediction market a scientifically
proven way of using the wisdom of the
crowd to create more accurate
predictions about future events
prediction markets have been shown to
work much better than other forecasting
methods like polling or expert analysis
in many cases and futur has actually
taken the concept and turned it into a
fun easy to use social game you open up
the futur app and you'll see a whole
range of forecasts covering topics
across the board from politics to sports
and everything in between you can check
out my predictions and follow me to get
updates on my profile which is linked to
in the description if you're watching
this on youtube the tour is a great tool
to find out more about the world improve
your forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody their
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur comm sign up and start making
for
caste it's free and it's available on
both Android and iOS as well as on web
browsers and that's f UT uu r dot com